Muhammad Farah has been a farmer for
most of his life the sale of dates from
these palm trees have helped him put
food on the table but not anymore he
says in the past few years his Harvest
has been decreasing
this year there isn't a single date
fruit on the trees and the year before
there was very little this all started
with the gold mining company started
operating here shortly after they came
we started to notice the changes in the
trees and the harvests
is known for its reserve of gold Sudan's
main source of heart currency artisanal
Miners and companies use mercury and
cyanide to separate the mineral from its
ore and Farmers say the wastes from the
products used to extract the precious
mineral have affected crops here
this is the stream that Waters thousands
of hectares of Farmland here in Abu
Hamid several mining companies are
around this area residents blame the
Mercury and cyanides used to extract
gold for not only the changes in
Farmland but other changes to
the stream is also a water source for
herders and their livestock Muhammad
Ahmed says drinking from it has affected
his sheep's health
they have dreamers some are born with
mutations some die
this all started happening after the
companies arrived I've lost so many
sheep and they have my source of income
how can someone buy them from me when
they're sick local authorities say steps
will be taken to ensure waste materials
from the companies do not affect those
living in Abu how much further
[Music]
we've sent teams and investigated the
environmental impact of the companies
based on the findings all the companies
near populated areas were asked to move
to a safe distance where we believe the
operations will not have an impact on
the residents
there were mistakes made in mining
operations waste was not treated
properly but we will try to fix what has
been damaged
but for those like Muhammad Farah it's
too late and he says it could be a long
time before his farm is profitable again
Heber Morgan Al Jazeera Abu Hamid River
Nile state